Alright guys, so in the final trading strategy video, we are going to learn ABCD trading strategy. This one is just like ABCD, but it's a reversal. So I'm going to explain what it looks like, but let me explain it. So this is the ABCD trading strategy. Right? Now, what is the D here? No, what is ABCD, but what is the D here?
So we got the A wave, we got the B wave, then we got the C wave, right?
This is pretty much it.
But then we got the D wave, right?
That takes out this high, sorry, this low, right?
This is your take profit.
When you, so let me just draw it in a more clear way.
So you will get your entry at the retest, right?
Or some auto block over here.
And then you see price take out this low.
And then what you want to do is you want to wait
for price to go back up again.
And then you want to take entry again from this level.
And it will go up there.
So this is APCD fitting strategy.
Let me explain once again.
So what we have is a A, B, C, right?
Pretty much it.
Then we wait for the D move that breaks the,
the low of the B move, right?
And then price goes up, root has this level,
or some fair value gap down there.
And it goes all the way up.
Very simple trading strategy guys.
So let me show you an example.
So what do we have here?
We got the A with.
We got the B with.
And we got the C with, right?
Let me put this like this.
Put it like this.
And bam.
We broke this level.
Very nice.
nice. So as you can see, let me remove that. We got this level. We broke this level. We reclaimed
this level. Didn't quite break the structure over here, but this is a new accession trading
strategy. And sometimes it couldn't work in the land session as well. Only sometimes, okay?
So keep that in mind.
So as you can see, when price breaks this level, which is, sorry, my bad, this level.
So you can see we got the A, we got the B, we got the C, and then we got the D.
The D takes out the low of the B move, the B leg, right?
And then it reclaims that level.
You can enter on the retest here, put your stop-loss below this low, and go for one
to two.
That is pretty much it.
This is a very simple setting strategy guys.
They are going to be endless opportunities for you to enter the market.
As you can see, for more confluence, it also broke some structure here.
So let me point this out.
Then we had a very tiny imbalance around this level.
So let me put this in this.
There's very tiny balance that I can see.
Let me zoom it in.
Yep.
price just ripped it off this auto block and it went all the way up.
So let me give you one more example.